in a sunny valley a curtain of gloom and
fear has fallen amidst this beauty a
picture of how coronavirus is wrecking
france more than two thousand people
have died in this region it's full of
small nervous villages like this one
corny mom cassandra helps care for some
of the elderly residents here she's had
the virus so have many of her clients
one of them has died here Naboo a doctor
just over here her mother was more young
safe kazillion miss Russia damn she went
among the concentration we are separated
critical and there is a focal point to
all this anxiety it's here on the edge
of the village a nursing home over the
past month in this single building 25
residents have died because of kovat 19
ctmc extremely profound resident
bacterial super drew the world on this
year
onaji medusa staff here have told us
that they were overwhelmed when
coronavirus first broke out they were
staggered by the speed with which it
passed from patient to patient but in
those first few weeks people who died in
retirement homes like this one were not
included in government statistics about
victims of this virus it's only in the
past few days that those deaths have
been included and that has added
thousands to the number of people who
have died from coronavirus across France
France is now reacting there will be a
lot more testing at the nation's care
homes but here it feels too late
Coenen are still carries the scars of
past wars of trauma it has survived but
how do you reconcile yourself to
something like this
[Music]
no Vilas musica Merapi Vassar Holloway
June situatio OC complex Nazi occupation
settle more more dialysis situatio good
umami squamous over Nevada against us
your pie this is a portrait of the
pandemics power a village crushed by
cruel blend of death illness and fear
Adam Parsons Sky News corny Mong